- [Instructor] Earlier in
your algebraic careers,
you learned how to multiply polynomials.
So for example, if we had x
plus two times four x plus five,
we learned that this is the same thing
as really doing the
distributive property twice.
But you can multiply x times
four x to get four x-squared.
You can multiply x times
five to get five x.
You can multiply two times
four x to get eight x.
And you can multiply two
times five to get 10.
If what I just did looks foreign to you,
I encourage you to review
multiplying binomials on Kahn Academy.
But then this could be simplified as being
four x-squared plus 13x plus 10.
What we will now do as we
advance our algebraic careers
is to think about how do
we go the other way around?
How do we divide polynomials?
So for example, we might
see an expression like this.
Four x-squared plus 13x plus
10 divided by x plus two.
Now, you might already
know from your knowledge
of multiplication and
division that this is really
reversing what we just did up here,
that if x plus two times four x plus five
is equal to this business,
then this business
divided by x plus two should
be equal to four x plus five.
And even if you didn't
have this information
that we have up here,
there's ways that you
would've approached this.
One way is that you
could've tried to factor
what we have here in the numerator.
You could've said hey, let me
maybe factor this by grouping.
And let's do that right over here.
Four x-squared plus 13x plus 10.
When you factor by grouping, you say hey,
can I think of two numbers whose product
is equal to four times 10?
So I say a times b is equal to 40.
And whose sum is equal to 13.
So a plus b is equal to 13.
And let's see what it could be.
It could be eight and five.
So a is equal to eight,
b is equal to five.
This is just factoring by
grouping right over here.
Once again, if this is unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to review
factoring by grouping on Kahn Academy.
And so we can break apart this 13x
as an eight x and a five x.
So we can rewrite this as four x-squared
plus eight x plus five x plus 10, plus 10.
And notice, it's just re,
undoing what we did up here.
But we're assuming we don't even know
about what we did up here,
that someone just gave us
this quadratic and said factor it.
And then here you could say
all right, for these first
two terms, I could factor out a four x.
So it becomes four x times x plus two.
And then these second two terms,
I could factor out a five.
So plus five times x plus two.
And then I can factor out an x plus two.
So it becomes, it becomes x plus two.
I'll scroll down a little bit.
It become x plus two, I'm
just factoring that out,
times four x plus five, four x plus five,
which is exactly what we had up there.
And so you could rewrite this expression
that involves division,
sometimes called a
rational expression, as,
we could rewrite this as x plus
two times four x plus five,
all of that over x plus two.
And as long as x does
not equal negative two,
we can divide the
numerator and denominator
by x plus two and we're going to be left
with four x plus five.
And we could constrain it.
We could say for x not
equaling negative two.
This is just a little bit of a primer.
As we go deeper, we'll do many,
many, many examples of this.
And we'll also see that
there's other techniques
other than just factoring
this numerator over here.
And we're going to do it with
higher degree polynomials,
third degree polynomials.
And we're gonna learn something
known as polynomial division
where it's going to look an awful lot,
and it's actually gonna
have a lot of similarities,
with the long division
that you likely learned
in probably fourth or fifth grade,
where we're gonna take
expressions like x plus two
and we're gonna divide it into
four x-squared plus 13x plus 10.
And instead of place value,
we'll have a new notion
of place value which
is around which degree
term you're thinking about.
So we're gonna do things
like, and we're gonna do these
completely in other
videos, hey, how many times
does x go into four x-squared?
Hey, it goes four x times.
So you'd write the four x there
and then you'd multiply
four x times x-squared.
You get four x-squared.
Four x times two is eight x.
Then you subtract these.
And then you keep going
just like you would
typically do long division.
13x minus eight x is five x.
And then you bring that 10 down.
And then you say hey, how many times
does x go into five x?
And you say hey, it goes five times.
Five times x is equal to five x.
Five times two is equal to 10.
And then you subtract this
and you're left with no remainder.
And so notice, you just
saw when x plus two
is divided into this,
you get four x plus five,
just what we saw right over there.
So we're gonna explore
these multiple techniques,
including polynomial division.
And we're also going to see what happens
when you do have a remainder there.